hello it is time for drew's news your
ice cold good new slushy without that
painful brain freeze and with me at the
desk is my little slush puppy rusty ross
mantha
hi everybody
well first up in the headlines we really
gravitated towards this because the
friends ross and rachel debate that will
never die
what does it exactly mean when you're
on a break
well according to bustle it means
whatever you want it to
but both partners gotta be on the same
page a break doesn't necessarily mean a
break up therapists say that you have to
do this right
both people have to want whatever they
choose a hundred percent and you gotta
accept crystal clear parameters are we
dating other people are we canoodling
first second third base the whole
enchilada arugula and finally
you gotta set a concrete date for coming
back together and hashing out what needs
to change
ross what thought so
i don't like this at all i think if
you're news flash if you're on a break
you're single because
the whole point of being in a
relationship is learning from each other
working through things if you're going
to tap out when times get tough you're
not ready for a relationship bottom line
bottom line i never liked
on a break on a break
you don't take a break
i just move on if you're taking a break
just move on that's not gonna work out
sorry uncle ross just broke the news too
sorry
um hey yeah ross of a different kind
what do you mean of the ross and rachel
now understood okay hey uh
moving on we've got a hulk a new kind of
steak in food news this is weird
okay food and wine reports the internet
debut of get this you guys the
dishwasher steak
that is a steak that is prepared
in your dishwasher
yeah i know but it's taking the internet
by storm take a look at this
no soap no dishes just the steak one
hour 45 minutes
and we're going oh
my god
and we have a sous-vide steak
why why
why when there are so many other options
right there in the kitchen that get hot
can cook a steak
this is what makes me realize that when
we all thought we were like laymen in
the kitchen cooking our lean cuisine
that we were just sous-viding the whole
time oh so soothing is what you put it
in plastic and it sort of sucks it like
fat it's a vacu-seal it's usually a
vacuole and then it's like
it's cooked in hot water right or is it
steamed steam some hot water right again
lean cuisine hello people we've been
fancy all along well okay here we have
one these were cooked
in our dishwasher also um they are
seared afterwards so apparently the hot
water sous vide process tenderizes and
gets this perfect cook on it which i
have to say up front i feel a little
guilty one steak an hour and 45 minutes
of hot water not the most efficient okay
that's true so you have a real beef with
this
i do rossi i do
but then you steer it and i gotta say
this looks pretty good
[Music]
okay
i don't want to like this i don't want
to like it either but it's so good
it's about the texture too which is that
whole souvenir thing and the um
the dishwasher what
man i'm never gonna do this but i am
going to eat this yeah and it's not
carbs and it's not for the first time
here at the desk she's not force-feeding
me carbs actual protein thank you i know
i'm sorry i'm always force-feeding your
carbs why is it so i'm like a little
bird that comes in your like in your
nest and is constantly like shoving
carbs down your throat i got croissants
today i know yum i do
[Music]
you